guys like a guy that looks to you to
make decisions
i would say
like what do you mean like what kind of
decisions um just like if there's a big
decision you have to make in your
household and instead like he doesn't
like he looks to you to make it instead
of making it himself
um
it's an interesting scenario i don't
think i've been in that scenario before
i've never been on that scene
give us give us an actual realistic
scenario that would happen um a
realistic scenario um you have to decide
what
where you're going to move or what like
just a pulpit or something yeah a house
you're going to buy that's a big
decision
i don't think i would mind it at all
honestly
but i mean i also like would like his
opinion i guess because i don't want to
like move us all in one place and then
have him resent me for doing that what
about what about like dates when he asks
you like to plan the date would you
i mean i don't mind that i like really
you don't like that no not at all i'm
like a foodie so i'm like i will huh
your partner
you know
tell us
i know i know i know too
um
you know us guys like we're not really
that creative now 2020 is more or less
like oh let's get some food and watch a
movie that's us all like good stop pause
rewind it again i said i was first date
no no no like yeah yeah i felt like
thursday i know it's gotta be a little
bit of fun like go to most people like
top goal something i got active right
but for the most part it's a dinner
movie
you gotta talk slower
the accent
i just like like the i'm so sorry
i apologize i apologize first and
foremost you shouldn't be taken to any
you shouldn't be taking a go to the
movies on a date unless you've been
dating for a long long time yeah because
then you just sit there not talking
he gets it he gets it
um you come forward sorry
i'm getting that right i'm sorry
that's that's uh no don't do that um and
as i was saying to you it was a first
date it was a first date and a guy said
to you hey
let's meet up
you choose you it's all in your hands so
you pick it yeah you take the time you
use a date you pay for it
okay i mean i respect that he's like
putting like the control in my hands but
i want the controller but i find it more
attractive when he's taking the control
himself
so if he's like okay
oh let's go on a date i'll make a
reservation somewhere then i'm like oh
that's attractive because he's making
plans like i'm not pushing him to do
anything if he's putting the control in
my hand it sends a different message i
would say like like when they do plan it
out it makes it seem like they are
really interested in yes and they like
want it more you know because then
they're like okay let's do this isn't
this mess and they like have a mind
already like have a thing in their mind
like they're like thinking about what's
going to happen and with the equality of
dating in the way men approach like
dating
and dating i don't think there is
because
men don't have that many options and we
all know like men will swipe right and
all women on tinder and then get a few
matches and it's kind of the opposite
for women
yeah like women don't have to swipe that
often but we'll get matches that kind of
thing and just the way that men approach
women and get dates i feel like because
it's like formulated in that way that
men's kind of approaching the woman the
man is approaching the woman that they
should kind of organize the day like it
doesn't make sense to change that
when it's out that way so straight i'm
going to ask the question so sorry for
you go ahead
the girls in the tunnel is this um so
just a quick yes or no and now later
second question
do you feel that there should be i don't
answer that question so should there be
gender roles in a relationship yes or no
um i think some gender roles are good no
no yes or no yes or no
how traditional gender roles should they
exist do i not get asked the
questions yes
yes but not like everything you know
like not like the old traditional but i
would say like some of them still i
think there's a bit of flexibility
within the gender roles yeah but i do
think that there's a positive side to it
so what about equality then
because i
want to pause before you answer i want
to say something about it okay
equality says everything's equal right
gender roles existed when things weren't
equal
yeah i'll say do you have two things
are
not they can't work together
you think they're not mutually exclusive
i don't think that's true anymore i do
think there's gender roles and equality
and do you think you can just do
bring what you can bring to the table
and this other person brings what they
can bring to the table and you kind of
match that and you kind of
if i do the cooking you can do the
cleaning or that kind of thing where you
both work together as a team at the end
result is equality that you both feel
like everyone's committed to the
relationship so it's not that i'm doing
more tasks than you it's more like i'm
helping you you're helping me and you
feel like it's working so okay no would
you say like there are generals they're
just not as restricted as before then i
think there are gender roles and i don't
think there's a problem with that yeah
but i don't think they're more flexible
so you can choose who has the gender
role
like who's going to be the person in the
house like the house man or housewoman
and then they'll have their their roles
within that the roles of the house
person who's staying at home it's not
like just the woman or just the man for
example so where i kind of describe that
is this
you would expect
as women i i'm i'm gonna make an
assumption you could have come wrong but
i i assume that you'd expect that man
pays you especially the first couple of
dates you spend time with us um i mean
not fully i mean so like i just like
went to paris and i was like
oh like let me you know for a while but
i guess so okay you're right you're
right
he you went out for dinner you planned
it he made you ask for you to plan it
and expected you to pay for the drinks
and dinner whatever you did in the first
day how would you have felt at the time
would you have seen him again
probably not like god
that is bad you're gonna date on a guy
you've met a guy online or wherever any
shop numbers are talking for a while he
goes hey let's meet up he says you plan
it you put a date you put a time you pay
for it
how do you feel i
i wouldn't feel positive towards it
because what's the point of me like
dating i don't know like having someone
being in a relationship someone like
you're supposed to benefit from that
and if i'm making my own
you're financially stable you've got a
job you've got everything you need in
life why do i need to pay for a date for
a man
but i mean okay but you because you said
that if he was to ask me on a date i
would say if you're asking me on a date
then you want to take me on one so you
should be paying you're taking the
initiative to want to take me exactly
yeah when i get out of here women for
dates
i promise you what they do when like if
they're dating someone you're like oh
let's go out let's have a first date
there's a woman meets a guy in a bar
chats him out guts his number talks to
him i think this happens more than you
think i think women push like a kind of
a catalyst for most relationships like
oh like we should meet up they push
things in that direction men are
sometimes a bit slow it's like okay i
directly want to go on a date they might
talk for ages if a woman doesn't
intervene but regardless like that
wasn't the point of the thing it wasn't
like do women ask men on date it's the
point was he pays when men ask women on
date
like why
yeah pay for the date so reason reason
asks questions
because this
might as well in my opinion that the two
things that you can't have gender
equality but then expect traditional
outcomes
i don't think the constitutional outcome
is that we are a date we pay for a day
yeah but i mean okay but if women were
supposed to like were to ask you on the
day
no
i said if women were to were to ask you
on a date you don't
okay but that's not the point here
if you were to no no no no
yeah and then
i mean i don't think they would they
would pay for the date weren't they
this is like a cultural thing i think
it's more about like culture than to do
with like gender equality so sometimes
we have traditions that just cultured
make sense for western culture that's
kind of like the gentleman kind of
stereotype just doing that no you're
going that extra mile for us
i can't i'll say a gentleman couldn't
exist in today's society if you have
equality it wouldn't didn't you already
existed in a time when men
out earned
we might like to work we had to do all
right so there were things that men had
to do for women for to be chivalrous if
you're all equal then why am i cheating
especially why would you be more special
it's culturally equal
if we're equal
it's a grand gesture
[Music]
okay you've got two bags of shopping and
a guy opens the door for you like for
another guy
do you appreciate the chivalry i want
this is where the difference is right
it's like look it's one thing you're
like cool i'm not saying like yeah if
i'm walking outside like
my hands are full yeah and someone opens
the door like a guy who was walking past
me that's that's like helpful i wouldn't
consider anything like that but i
wouldn't expect a man to be like yeah
yeah
open the door for me and be like yeah
sit down close it for me move back
around like where we going like no i
would never we're in the car and i come
around to open the door for you to let
you in the car
like a man invented the revolving door
what a man invented the revolving door
because he didn't want to open doors for
women maybe thank you
thank you
he
no he actually has a decent point
because a common complaint i hear from
matt is that women want equality but
only when it benefits us
and so this is kind of a situation where
like yeah we want the date
yeah we want to be courted yeah but
at that cost yeah but like isn't that
human nature to try and get as much as
you can for as little
effort as possible yeah
you work the best job or like
that earns the most money maybe not
because it's like
nourishing for your mind you just do
what you can do that gives you the best
reward and i think that comes for dating
and equality as well i think maybe
that's probably why women like it when
men paper dates because
so do you think men should put up with
that is the question i mean men have a
choice they can say no yeah they can say
i'm not paying them i'm asking do you
think they should
it's up to men to make that decision
yeah they do to be honest
nah nah i've been to enough days right
where like obviously
i've paid obviously you know but like
with something someone what girls like
miss on that is like we don't do it like
okay we're obviously gonna pay right but
i just like that's that's from that's me
anyways um but it's like we don't do it
just because of like you know we got we
got a day so that we want it because we
took the time of that day to meet you to
talk to you we show that we want you
know i mean that and then when life for
example when something goes wrong and
then like oh you take that first date or
you get the food you get wherever you
get everything paid for you're all happy
and stuff like that but then you ghost
the man that [ __ ] that's just what
that's just really that's really you
know i mean that just breaks a man like
you know it's not that's not cool let me
give you a sec sorry can i give you a
second
never think i've gotten that date but
first date
for a meal don't do it
never do it this is me man talk to me
yeah you know yeah that's cool about it
where you where are you taking them to
the park
right i mean
you love it
date how much money is too much money to
put into a first date that's a good
question
it depends on how much you like the girl
it depends on how much interest you have
in the world yeah like what if you've
been talking on the phone
i'm like
so you can talk
you could be talking on the phone and
but i guess it depends on how you've met
but um you can find that
sometimes you might be in a bar or
something you see someone to come out
and see the daytime full glare of the
sun then
um if you're on a date and you don't
like the guy would you like pay for half
the date because you know you're not
going to see him again because i feel
like if you know that something's not
going well like i would feel bad like
making the person pay for like a whole
day so i'll always like try and paste
like i know that like okay
here's here's my problem okay i got
yes sometimes like i'd want to do that
but i'm really i feel awkward
yeah
like how do you initiate that
because i feel like
like if he he's insisting to pay right i
don't want to be like oh no don't pay i
never want to see you again
it's not where you pay for it
so you say oh let's go huffs yeah what
you saying right do the checkbook
no i know but a lot of guys won't let
you
so like i'll just pull out like my cash
and be like yeah
okay
i don't know i always offer to split it
regardless just because like i don't
know you never know like the other
person's financial issue
that's true but i never really do that
actually i'm taking a date you've got a
holistic date yeah i don't normally do
that but i do seem like it's a nice
gesture to do because then you're really
considering the person and maybe
it was just like the equality of dating
like
women invest in as much as men are
investing because we women don't as
invest as much as men on like a first
date i think it kind of equalizes that
and that's nice but i just i can't see
myself doing it i've seen i've seen a
lot of women like on po like on other
podcasts and stuff like that there was
one general where it's like
they just oh i wouldn't uh there was one
very big one i think we've talked about
this in the one of the previous ones
where the guy's like i would not buy
this man a present and then if he gets
sick i can't walk i have to get myself a
new man like wait what yeah so there was
a girl on one of the podcast right she
goes listen
he has me as the gift as a i would not
buy him a person because he said me as a
president he has me for this for this
for this and then this guy asked him he
was like listen god forbid your man
got sick and can't work he goes i'd have
to i'd have to find myself a new man
like that mentality in women why was he
with her
no no he wasn't it was just a podcast
that he spoke that you spoke about
okay guys i